and Boston Globe comm investigates the
children of Catholic priests the paper
reports there are thousands of people
who have strong evidence they are sons
or daughters of clergy members they say
they're often neglected or shamed into
silence in an interview you'll see only
on CBS this morning Boston Globe
spotlight team reporter Micheal R is n
DS is here but first we have a look at
spotlights legacy of groundbreaking
reporting Gagan is accused of molesting
dozens of children from the 1960s until
his retirement in 1993 in 2002 the
Boston Globe spotlight teen ran more
than 600 reports revealing a scandal
within the Catholic Church
hundreds of priests had sexually abused
thousands of children over decades and
church leaders covered it up
unprecedented calls for the resignation
of the most powerful man in the American
Catholic Church Cardinal Burnett law the
paper won a Pulitzer Prize for the
coverage hey Lou and they let it happen
to kids okay the reporters became the
story in the 2015 movie spotlight and
the Oscar days Cheney won two Oscars
including Best Picture spotlight this
morning the spotlight team unveils a new
report on what it calls a worldwide and
systemic problem within the Catholic
Church priests fathering illegitimate
children I was blaming myself I was his
mistake by him having a child I was his
mistake well we reached out to Vatican
officials for a statement regarding this
new reporting from the Boston Globe calm
but they declined to comment the Boston
Globe's Michael Resendez joins us now
good morning good morning first this is
incredible reporting I know you spent so
much time on it first how many children
of priests might there be well we know
there are many more than people assume
probably in the thousands just recently
about two years ago son of a priest in
Ireland set up a website called coping
international and he's heard from scores
of people from all over the world who
are the sons and daughters of Catholic
priests what prompted you to start this
investigation I first heard from a
fellow named
Jim Graham who's in the story today on
globe comm and Jim spent many years
tracking down evidence that a priest was
his father I was impressed with what he
suffered the pain he endured and I was
impressed with his detective work but
still it was just one person and it
wasn't until vincent doyle called me and
gave me the information he'd collected
through his website but i realized this
was a systemic situation and deserved my
full attention
systemic is an interesting word because
it is said that the church would like
you to believe these are very rare
exceptions yes that's correct
I think it's very similar to the
situation with clergy sex abuse whenever
ever there was a scandal the church
treated the situation as if it was
exceptional when in fact it was systemic
and I think we're looking at the same
thing here I think most people wouldn't
even think about the children of priests
but when you when you really play it out
it makes sense that there would be
children of priests and then you write
in the article that many of them suffer
they have to suffer in silence they have
to suffer in secrecy how does it affect
them growing up well I think they suffer
emotionally I think they suffer
financially I think they suffer
spiritually by not having a loving
father and very often by not having a
father who provides adequate child
support so what will happen to those who
now are identified as fathers of
children well these people are coming
together it's remarkable to see this
community being formed right now as we
speak and they would like the church the
Vatican to put some policies in place to
end the secrecy and also just give some
bishops a little bit of guidance on what
to do when they learn one of their
priests has fathered a child because
right now they have no guidance but my
god go ahead go ahead north while the
Vatican has not been clear Cardinal Sean
O'Malley has and he has been an advisor
to the Pope in the heads of the Pope's
Advisory Commission on protecting minors
and he gave this statement to us at CBS
News he said this if a priest father's a
child he has a moral obligation to step
aside from ministry and provide for the
care and needs of the mother and the
child in such a moment their welfare is
the highest priority is this a moment to
for leaders of the church like Cardinal
O'Malley who responded to the original
spotlight report to do something serious
about this I think so and I think
Cardinal O'Malley statement is important
because I think more
not the first reaction of a priest is to
cover up the fact that he has become
apparent and what Cardinal O'Malley is
saying and and I think this is in line
with some of the things Pope Francis has
said is know if you're a priest and your
father a child your first responsibility
is no longer to the church it's to your
child this was interesting you talked
about in the African context but you
said this is not isolated celibacy means
a priest does not get married but that
does not mean he cannot have children
does that make sense yes I think in
other parts of the world many parts of
the world priest may have a different
idea about what celibacy is and what the
expectations are of a priest oh this is
happening the same time they Cardinal is
in Australia yes attending himself yes
Cardinal Pell exactly all right powerful
card Cardinal Pell is a third highest
ranking official at the Vatican he's
been criminally charged in Australia as
you said and it's very very significant
development I think it's significant
because after all these years of having
to confront the problem the Vatican has
still not come up with a set of policies
for dealing with the problem of clergy
sexual abuse in our most of these
children born from abuse are they from
consensual relationships oh I think very
often they're from consensual
relationships you know I think for
instance many of the the mothers never
file for child support because they
still love the father of their children
they often they're devout Catholics who
believe that the the man who fathered a
child is not only a father but a
representative of God and often they
were told I'm gonna get out of the
priesthood and we'll be together yes I
think some of the some of the mothers
have really been strung along for many
many years
thanks Michael great reporting strong
reporting thank you so much Michael
Resendez part two of the spotlight teams
investigation will be published on
Sunday on Boston Globe calm